alright one more thing on the Reuben
report we just started this last week
just one final thought and it's
something that you started talking about
a little bit earlier I wanted to when
you guys truly felt like you arrived
because I can honestly tell you that
this moment right this second the fact
that i'm sitting here with Melissa who I
started doing stand-up with and who has
gone on to so many great things and that
the way that we connected on Twitter and
that you're sitting here and that I knew
Melissa always loved what you did and
that I was able to bring you two
together this is truly one of those
moments for me and I want to know when
for both of you guys you felt like you
took the words right out of my mouth
actually this why come on no I'm serious
watching Jack hey watch me do an
imitation of her when I was seven years
old like that to me is very it's very
full circle to me and very exciting well
Jack hey if you now say this is your
moment to this whole place is gonna
explode so no that's not know when was
it what was it for you that you really
thought okay it's okay now I'm here
actually happens every day because
little girls come up to me and boys
three and four five years old okay
that's when you know you've arrived you
know cuz its longevity you can stay
around long enough and still be viable
and so you know it makes you feel good
you know you don't feel like when you
get out of the tub you have to push the
button you know it it really doesn't
keep survivor but I knew I had up I made
it um when I went into a restaurant
Milton Berle said oh it comes gladys
knight in the pits hey Jack hey you know
I wasn't my brothers haha I knew I made
I was insulted but I remember going he
knows me I couldn't believe it and I he
showed me some other things so we'll
talk about that another show oh he
showed you though you know that you know
what she's referring to yes I want her
to true it's true come on Cooper flop
okay anyway whoa did it actually make
that sound yeah but is that it would be
greater be online what is Jack hey
talking about
now is that really a comedy inside or
thing we know what we're talking about
but to the people i feel like its most
people knows we're if you know gentleman
broadest they ask me from 1 / yeah who
wouldn't he showed it to you here we're
talking about Milton Berle's penis is
the moment that you felt that you
arrived with no women called my name
when he said hey Jack hey and this is
loud it's like a moose on Frank's old us
you know when you go and I was all
dolled up you know I used to go up
dolled up every day by the way I'll
heals everything Lonnie answer taught me
i was done up everywhere I went see I
feel like I need to learn from that
you're rolling a 14 really does work
really really I mean Kim Kardashian for
everything people say you don't say
about her she's stunning she is I met
her and I went oh I see she every day
you would get up and lashes everything
and it was at work do you know now I was
heading entourage but now Chum I don't
want anybody with me well I huh I think
we're just gonna keep doing this will
shut the cameras but we're gonna keep
going I genuinely genuinely thank you
guys and both of you are well you know
how I feel about you and Jack hey now
you know too and I thank you guys for
watching and again thank you guys and
we'll keep talking we'll get some
fashion tips from Jacqueline alright
thanks guys we'll see in a scramble asst
bonobos calms the official outfitter of
the Ruben report enter code TR are 20
for twenty percent off your first
purchase